I'm wondering if I should sell my
personal car and just use my boyfriend's
company car his personal car to pay off
some of my debt I I if you're my sister
or you're my daughter or you're just one
of my buddies who's a woman I would tell
you if he marries you great yall make
financial decisions together and yall go
in and share a car and all that yeah if
it's a
boyfriend I mean Jade and I would not
have jobs if every every well-laid plan
ended right and so you're you're selling
your car exposing yourself to him and
his company which happens to be your
company too that's just a lot of you are
hitching Your Wagon to some unsecure
horses and getting dragged into the wild
right that's that just makes me nervous